we can do much better than that
we can look for artifacts that they left
behind even
even if they are dead you can look for
industrial pollution
in the atmosphere supplements why do i
bring this up
again to show you the conservatism of
the mainstream in astronomy and
by the way i shouldn't you know i have
leadership positions i was chair of the
astronomy department for nine years the
longest serving chair at harvard
and i'm the chair of the board on
physics and astronomy
of the national academies you know it's
the primary
board and you know i'm director of two
centers at harvard and so forth
so i i do represent the community
in in various ways but at the same time
you know i'm a little bit disappointed
by the conservatism that people have
and so let me give you an illustration
of that so the astronomy community
actually is going right now through the
process of defining its goals for the
next decade
and there are proposals for telescopes
that would cost
billions of dollars and whose goal is to
find
evidence for oxygen in the atmosphere of
planets around other stars
with the idea that this would be a
marker a signature
of life now the problem with that is
earth didn't have much oxygen in its
atmosphere for the first two billion
years
roughly half you know half of its life
it didn't have much oxygen but it had
life
it had microbial life it's not an it's
not clear yet
as of yet what the origin is for the
rise in the oxygen level after two
billion years about 2.4 billion years
ago
but we know that a planet can have life
without oxygen in the atmosphere because
earth did it
the second problem with this approach is
that you can have oxygen from natural
processes
you can break water molecules and make
oxygen right
so even if you find it it will never
tell you that for sure
life exists there and so even with these
billions of dollars the mainstream
community
will never be confident but uh
whether there is life now how can it be
confident there is actually a way
if instead of looking with the same
instruments if you look for molecules
that indicate
industrial pollution for example cfcs
you know that are produced by
refrigerating systems or industries here
on earth
that they do the ozone layer you know
you can search for that and i wrote a
paper
five years ago suggesting that now
what's the problem
you can just tell nasa i want to build
this
telescope to search for oxygen but also
for industrial pollution nobody would
say that yeah because it sounds
like you know on the periphery of the
field
and i asked you why would hilarious
because that's exactly i mean
that's what you're saying is quite
brilliant i mean uh
because it's a really strong signal and
if life
if there's alien civilizations out there
then they're probably going to be
many of them and they're probably going
to be more advanced than us
and they're probably going to have
something like industrial pollution
which would be a much
stronger signal than some basic gas
which could have a lot of different
explanations so like something like
oxygen or
i mean i don't you know
i mean we could talk about signs of life
on venus and so on
but like if you want a strong signal it
will be pollution
i love how garbage is no but the
pollution you have to understand
we think of pollution as a problem but
on a planet that was too
cold for example to have a comfortable
life on it
you can imagine terraforming it and
putting a blanket
of polluting gases such that it will be
warmer
and that would be a positive change so
if an industrial or or a technological
civilization
wants to terraform a planet that
otherwise is
is too cold for them they will do it so
what's the problem of
defining it as a search goal
using the same technologies the problem
is
that there is a taboo we are not
supposed to discuss
extraterrestrial intelligence there is
no funding for this subject
not much very little and young
people because of the bullying on
twitter you know
all the social media and elsewhere young
people with talent that are curious
about this
these questions do not enter this field
of study
and obviously if you step on the grass
it will never grow right so if you don't
give funding
obviously you know the mainstream
community says look nothing was
discovered so far
obviously nothing would be discovered if
talented
people go to other districts never you
never search for it
well enough you will never find anything
i mean look at gravitational wave
astrophysics it's a completely new
window into the universe pioneered by
ray weiss at mit
and at first it was ridiculed and
thanks to some administrators at the
national science foundation
it received funding despite the fact
that the mainstream of the astronomy
community
was very resistant yes to it and now
it's considered a frontier
so all these people that i remember as a
postdoc okay young postdoc these people
that bash this field said bad things
about people
you know said nothing will come out of
it now they say oh yeah of course you
know
the nobel prize was given to the you
know
to the ligo collaboration uh of course
now they're they're they're supportive
of it but my point is
if if if you suppress innovation
early on there are lots of missed
opportunities
the discovery of exoplanets is one
example you know in 1952 there was an
astronomer called the
named otto struve and he wrote the paper
saying
why don't we search for jupiter like
planets close to their host star because
if they're close enough
they would move the star back and forth
and we can detect the signal
yes okay and so astronomers
on time allocation committees of
telescopes for 40 years
argued this is not possible because we
know
why jupiter resides so far from the sun
you cannot have jupiter so close because
there is this region where ice forms far
from the sun
and beyond that region is where
jupiter-like planets can form
there was a theory behind it which ended
up being wrong by now by today's
standards but
anyway they did not give time on
telescopes to search for
such systems until the first system was
discovered
four decades after otto's through this
paper and the nobel prize was awarded to
that
just a couple of years ago yeah and you
ask yourself okay
so you know science still made progress
what's the problem
the problem is that this baby came out
barely you know and
and there was a delay of four decades so
the progress was delayed and i wonder
how many babies were not born
because of this resistance so there must
be ideas that are as good as this one
that were suppressed because they were
bullied because
people ridiculed them that were actually
good ideas and we
these are missed opportunities babies
that were never born yes
and you know i'm willing to push this
frontier of the search for
technologies or technological signatures
of other civilizations
because you know when i was young i was
in the military
uh in israel it's obligatory to serve
and
there was this saying that you know one
of the soldiers sometimes has to put
his body on the barbed wire so that
others
can go through and i'm willing to suffer
the pain
so that you know younger people in the
future
will be able to speak freely about the
possibility that some of the anomalies
we find in the sky
yes are due to technological signatures
you